نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين بان الانفجار الذي سمع في
العاصمه واشنطن مرتبط بملاحقه مقاتلات
لطائره صغيره دخلت المجال الجوي المحظور
فوق العاصمه الامريكيه قبل ان تسقط في
منطقه جماليه في ولايه فرجينيا في حين
نقلت وكاله رويترزام مسؤول امريكي قوله
بان طائره صغيره
انتهكت المجال الجوي والطائرات العسكريه
لم تتسبب في حدوث تصادم مدني فقالت اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه ان الطائره اقلعت من
مطار محلي في ولايه تشيلسي وكانت متجهه
الى مطار لونج ايلاند في نيويورك
هذا واظهر موقع تتبع الرحلات
24 ان الطائرات انعطفت فجاه عن مسار
الرحله المصرحه به وحلقت فوق العاصمه
واشنطن قبل ان تعترضها الطائرات الحربيه
يذهب الينا من واشنطن الان مراسل جزيره
محمد العالمي محمد مرحبا بك معنا اذا بعد
كل هذه الروايات فلتضحت الروايه النهائيه
الصوره بشكل اوضح لتحطم هذه الطائره
الصغيره
وربما ما توفر من اجوبه حتى الان تناسلت
عنه اسئله عده
وربما لن تعرف او لن تعرف اجابتها في
المستقبل القريب اولا طائره كما اشرت
اقلعت من تنيسي في الجنوب الغربي للعاصمه
متوجهه الى نيويورك وبعد ذلك استدارت دون
اي سبب واضح في اتجاه العاصمه واشنطن فوق
خط محظور التحليق فوقه فوق العاصمه بعد كل
قيود التي فرضت في عقاب الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر لما لوحد وجود تلك الطائره اقلعت
طائرتان اف 16 من قاعده اندروز الجويه في
ولايه ميريلاند على ضواحي العاصمه حيث كان
يوجد الرئيس بايدن يلعب الجولف مع اخيه
وهي القاعده الجويه التي تحتضن الطائره
الرئاسيه الفورسوان اقلعت طائرت يبدو ان
احدى الطائرتين العسكريتين حلقت على علو
منخفض
واخترقت جدار الصوت مما سبب حاله من الهلع
لدى سكان العاصمه وايضا في المقاطعات
القريبه في ولايه فرجينيا وميرلاند
القريبتين من العاصمه بعد ذلك تعاقبت
الطائرتان العسكريتان الطائره الصغيره يا
طائره طائره رجال اعمال ممكن ان يستقل
حوالي 12 راكبا حتى الان غير معروف عدد
ركاب الطائره
شبكه سيانات نقلت عن مصدر غير رسمي قوله
انه كان هناك اربعه ركاب على الطائره لكن
لربان ولا الذين كانوا معه على الطائره
استجابوا لمحاوله ربابنا العسكريين
التواصل معهم سواء بالاشاره او عن طريق
الراديو وهذا
مفهوم حتى الان هل كانت هناك حاله استعجال
فوق الطائره لماذا لم يتجاوب ركابها او
ربانها مع
الربانين العسكريين وايضا لماذا غيرت
تجاهها من نيويورك نحو
العاصمه واشنطن قبل ان
تصطدم باحد الجبال في ولايه فرجينيا حتى
الان كما اشرت قبل قليل محمد المسؤولون
الامريكيون يقولون ان تدخلهم بطائرتين سته
عشر لم يكن السبب المباشر لسقوط هذه
الطائره لكن كما قلت كل هذه التفاصيل
الجديده
اسفرت عن اسئله اخرى
ربما لن يتم التعرفه على اجوبتها في
المستقبل القريب الى ان يتم الوصول الى
اشلاء الطائره في جبال فرجينيا شكرا جزيلا